يستعدوا حلف شمال الاطلسي منورات عسكريه
في المانيا وصفت بالتدريبات الجويه الاضخم
منذ تاسيس الحلف كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا
في نقاشه مسارات ثلاثه ما اهداف هذه
المنورات وما السياقات الاقليميه والدوليه
التي تجري فيها السيب الحرب في اوكرانيا
كيف نقرا العلاقات الامريكيه الاوروبيه
وما هي حدود الاتفاق والاختلاف بين
الجانبين وبين الاوروبيين انفسهم وما هو
مستقبل دول الشرق اوروبا في ظل الصراع
المحمول بين الغرب وروسيا
في اطار ارسال رساله مهمه جدا لروسيا فيما
يتعلق بان هناك حاله اتحاد او وحده داخل
النيتو او الرساله هي رساله موجهه الى
روسيا بان هناك حاله اتحاد ان لم تكن
سياسيا على الاقل عسكريه فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في اوروبا خاصه في شرق اوروبا
باعتباره جدارا عازلا ما بين اوروبا
الغربيه وامريكا وبين روسيا الامر الثاني
متعلق بما نشهده على مدار اخر اسابيع فيما
يتعلق بالتوتر المتصاعد ومتزايد بين الصين
وبين امريكا خاصه فيما يتعلق بالبحر الصين
الجنوبي هناك حاله
توتر واضحه جدا للغايه وبالتالي هذه
المناورات تاتي في اطار ارسال رساله مهمه
جدا لاكبر قوتين عسكريتين في العالم هما
موسكو المناورات هذه جديده برسائلها لانها
تقول ان قدرته على الانتشار الجغرافي
واسعه جدا ان مفهوم الدفاع بات ايضا موضعه
بحث لان الدفاع يمكن ان يكون بمعنى ما
استباقي الرساله بهذا المعنى ترتبط
بالخريطه الاوروبيه بشكل اساسي وهذا ربما
اختلاف نوعي بين اوروبا وامريكا اذا كانت
امريكا ترسل رسائل الى الصين وليس فقط الى
روسيا ففي الحاله الاوروبيه التركيز هو
على الموضوع الروسي واوروبا تريد ان تقول
انها عادت لتصبح شريكه في الناتو في حلف
شمال الاطلسي وتصريح مكروع بهذا المعنى ان
روسيا اعادت احياء او ايقظت حلف شمال
الاطلسي من نومه العميق تشير الى القرار
باظهار عضلات عسكريه جويه
[موسيقى]
ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه وثلاث مناطق ومسارح
للعمليات هي اولا روسيا وشرق اوروبا قد
يعتبر هم كبير جدا فيما يتعلق باوروبا
تحديدا خاصه اوروبا الغربيه المسرح الثاني
متعلق بمصلحه الاندوبسيفنج او المحيط
الهادئ وهذا يرتبط بالاساس بالصين الصين
متواجده هناك بشكل اخر الامر الثاني متعلق
بالشرق الاوسط لكن اول منطقتين هما
المسرحين الرئيسيين لتحرك اي تحرك للنيتو
فيما يتعلق بالرد على الدفاع وبالتالي لا
يمكن الاطلاق النص بين الامرين بين وجود
مناورات جويها الاكبر في تاريخ النيتو بين
المخاطر العالميه التي تعتبر جديده جدا
فيما يتعلق بالنظام العالمي حاليا هناك
اعاده تموضع للقوات الدوليه خاصه بعد حرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كما قال الجنرال
العسكري هناك وضع عالمي جديد يتطلب وجود
جهزيه كامله لحلف الناتو متعلق مواجهته اي
تهديدات الاعتبار اوروبا انها غير معنيه
مباشره بتصاعد التوتر الصيني الامريكي بلا
شك ان الاوروبيين يعتبرون الصين تحديا
اقتصاديا
ويعيرون المساله الصينيه اهميه لكن ليس من
منطلق عسكري هذا المنطلق يخص الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اكثر والتميزات
الاوروبيه الامريكيه حتى الان ما زالت
قائمه على هذا الشعير
في قوانين حلف شمال الاطلسي لا يستطيع ان
يضم دوله او دول هي في حاله حرب وهذا يعني
ان اوكرانيا لن تنضم في القريب العاجل لكن
التوسيع الان برايي المفرمل ولو انه بعد
ضم فنلندا هناك مباحثات حول السويد ونعرف
الموقف التركي حتى الان من ذلك لكن غير
السويد المساله قد تكون مرتبطه اكثر
بابقاء العضويه على ما هي عليه بانتظار
نهايه لهذه الحرب التي قد تطول لفتره
اضافيه ومن بعدها جغرافيا حلف شمال
الاطلسي برايس يعاد النظر بها